if you're looking for ways to find
mentors be a good storyteller and find
your drive then this video is for you
first time I stood up the speaker I
stood up in my mind sat down I choked I
couldn't remember anything who are you
yeah what do you have and why should I
care people do business with people they
know like in trust and when you can
answer that now you're building a
rapport and a connection all of us get
in life what we are not what we want all
of us are self-made but only the
successful will admit it need motivation
watch it top ten of the leaf nation
what's up at seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
in that amazing thing you have inside
you that I want to see burst out into
the world so let's get your motivation
to attend and have you believing in you
grab a snack and chew on today's lessons
from a man who went from being labeled
mentally [ __ ] in grade school and
having to sleep in his office because he
couldn't afford a home to becoming one
of the greatest speakers of all time and
speaking to audiences as large as 80,000
people
he's Les Brown and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success volume three
enjoy
all right let's take things off with
rule number one don't lose time is there
anything that you wish you didn't do yes
I wish I had not waited 14 years
somebody said if you want to lose
something lose money you can get that
back eight out of ten millionaires have
been financially bankrupt Walt Disney
filed bankruptcy seven times that too
nervous breakdowns but don't lose time
there were 14 years I said on the
sidelines 14 years I said I don't have
an investor at me like Tony Robbins 14
years that said I don't have an MBA or a
PhD and I can't compete with these guys
I have the complexion of rejection 14
years I silenced my Wow and so I regret
that because there are some people that
maybe if they'd heard my voice they
would not have turned to drugs if they'd
heard my voice their lives would have
taken a different direction and I can't
get those 14 years back that haunts me
and me I think that drives me when I
speak with such energy I'm trying to
make up for that time mmm but I can't
this is the scariest clip of all I'm
just so worried about losing time I
think the idea of losing 14 years is
crazy and not just and not just getting
started because I've started and you may
have started but it's not playing pull
out it's not realizing you're
pretentious not doing the big thing that
you could do because you're playing at
70 75 percent and you're getting results
and everybody might be cheering you on
and saying look at how well you're doing
but you know you could do more that
kills me that constant push to want to
do something bigger and not feel like
I've wasted five years of my life or 14
years of my life doing the wrong thing
less it's a great clip to kick us off I
love it let's move on the rule number
two fail your way to greatness
I think that the people that are on that
are discovering how to unleash their
greatness are people who have the mental
resiliency
the courage to face failure if you will
fail your way to greatness that most
people allow their fear of failure
80% allow their fear of failure talk--we
their desire to succeed when you're
willing to fail again and again and
again when you make up your mind to
become unstoppable when you make up your
mind to become a no matter what person
then that will then give birth to a part
of yourself that you don't know right
now this is another common message it
keeps coming up in almost every single
top 10 you need to fail this most
successful people in the world fail the
most it just continues to happen
over and over and over again and then
you fail you suck and you feel you suck
and dimension failing you feel a little
bit better every single time and
eventually you end up hitting the home
run but you don't just get up to the
plate and smack a home run your first
time out you strike out a lot on your
way to success and so just viewing
failure differently failures feedback
failures a way to know not to do the
same thing again to get a little bit
smarter and improve for the next time
you bail your way to greatness let's get
the rule number three tell your story I
think most businesses fail most brands
never make it most people never reach
their greatness because they don't know
how to tell their story
yes that's major what will you be
sharing with the audience cuz look man
what story says yes while the story is
important is because when you speak if
you're selling yeah you an entrepreneur
you got a product you have an expertise
knowledge is a new currency yeah people
are asking three questions who are you
what do you have and why should I care
mm-hmm and so what if you don't answer
that because we know people do business
well who are you yeah what do you have
why should I care people do business
with people they know like in trust and
when you can answer that now you're
building a rapport and a connection that
creates the possibility where you can do
business together and help each other go
to that next level your story is your
chance to stand out as an entrepreneur
it's not about you anymore don't don't
think that telling your stories this big
ego play and you're building yourself up
it's not about you it's about your
customer
is about the connection if they feel
like they get the Y if they feel like
they get you they like you they trust
you they know you they feel like doing
business with you is doing business with
someone who actually cares about them
instead of work with some big
corporation where they're just another
number and they don't really have that
level of care that's important that's
how you win that's how you take on the
big competition
stop cutting your price and just show
people that you care through your story
I love that one let's keep it going rule
number four find your drive first time I
stood up to speak I stood up in my mind
sat down I choked I couldn't remember
anything yet I spoke in the Georgia Dome
I went to the bathroom seven times did I
tell you seven is about lucky they
knocked into a brownie I said what is it
come out man
Dexter Yeager they they up there pausing
now because it's time for you and I made
a mistake I looked out at the audience
and I panicked I said Mike I don't hear
the voices I'm scared
he said brownie they came to see you
you didn't come to see them he said come
out you were here the voices I said I
don't know Mike I've been trying I just
don't know I'm scared and he said just
be scared and do it anyhow don't speak I
said I'll help speak he said no I said
then what will I do he said just tell a
story mmm tell a story of where you are
about what you're going through and
about the goal and dream for buying your
mother home my vision of myself of
wanting to buy her home and and be able
to provide for her and I did that a for
what four different homes before she
passed that that drove me and so I think
it's important that people find
something that gives their life a sense
of meaning and value that drives them
that becomes their magnificent obsession
this is another great clip because if
you are off on some important mission
something big something that is pushing
you it's going to be scary you're gonna
have a lot of moments when you are
afraid
and you don't want to get up on stage
you don't want to make that phone call
you don't want to go to that meeting but
the thing that gets you through is not
just pretending like the fear is in
there because I fear is real it's having
the mission as having the drive as
having a purpose that you want to build
this better life for yourself and the
only way through it is crossing through
that wall of fear the wall of fear is
real and every great thing that you ever
do in your life will come as a result of
crossing that wall of beer find your
drive less I'm loving it so far let's
move on to rule number five fight for
what you want and one of the things I
emphasized that changing is not easy but
changing your life changing habits
reinventing yourself yeah
picking yourself up after life has
knocked you flat on your back I've got
to say when life knocks you down try and
land on your back because if you can
look up you could get up well that
sounds cute but that's not easy when I
was diagnosed with prostate cancer 17
years ago that first time that happened
I said hey I can handle this then when
he came back a year late I mean last
year 17 years later and this time it
metastasized to seven areas of my body
and ate 40% of my tea one vertebrae now
the stakes are higher is as life saying
okay mr. motivator you beat cancer the
first time what you'll do now uh I
started laughing when the doctor told me
said why are you laughing are you in
denial I said no I said I feel like
Mother Teresa he said what do you mean
she said Lord I know you know how much I
can bear I just wish you to have so much
confidence in me so the stakes are
higher so I've got to dig in and got to
fight more because at the end of the day
life is a fight for territory and once
you stop fighting for what you want what
you don't want will automatically take
over and so it's a fight it's a
challenge in life everyday and what we
have to do is embrace it what we have to
do is see it as a project to be worked
on it I read something once that I live
I said in life you will always be faced
with a series of god-ordained
opportunities
brilliantly disguised as problems and
challenges and so I see even cancer as a
gift as a god-ordained opportunity I
love it I think most people spend their
time complaining whining talking to the
friends but how they wish something was
a certain way we're the most successful
people the most success entrepreneurs
are the ones who see the opportunity in
the problem every major business that
was started that you look up to that you
love was started as a result of a
problem of most people complaining
around why some things are a certain way
and some bold entrepreneur decided to
say I'm not just gonna complain I'm
gonna find a way to fix that and boom a
business was born you've gotta fight for
what you want let's move on the rule
number six upgrade your relationships
things that affect most people that they
don't even realize I did not know that
my relationships affected me my mother
said Leslie if you run around with nine
broke people I guarantee you you'll be
called number two well come to find out
mama was right you don't had a
third-grade education but a studies
indicate MIT that you earn within two to
three thousand dollars of your closest
friends so so poverty and living a
mediocre life is communicated mind to
mine and so your relationships can hold
you down or they can lift you up so I
teach people to practice the principle
oqp only quality people
dr. Dennis Kimbrell said if you're the
smartest one in your group you need to
get a new group and so it's very
important that people upgrade their
relationships this is a fantastic point
and the way that I've solved that
personally is through the videos like
right now I'm hanging around with Les
Brown I'm learning I'm growing I'm
getting better I'm getting stronger and
so the more you can bring in people
actual people to have face-to-face
conversations with or online to learn
from videos and read books and get some
of those people's thoughts belief
systems habits mindsets to seep into you
makes such a huge difference if you do
that on a daily basis your quality of
life the quality of your business the
quality of everything that you aspire to
be and build will just explode
I believe it I've seen it I'm excited to
have a happy for you too let's go to
rule number seven don't do it for the
money when I speak it's not about me my
prayer is more of V less of me
I'm encouraging people who are serious
about speaking don't just do it for the
money you can make a lot of money I earn
more in one hour than ninety percent of
the American public earn working for
five years mm-hmm but when you find
something that you love you will study
it something that you love it becomes a
difference between being and speaking
and speaking being in you that you will
become not just confident but you'll
become competent on that this message is
so critical because in order to become
Michael Jordan world-class level talent
at anything you got to put in the work
you got to put in the work you got to
put in the Huss you got to put in the
drive and the only thing that gets you
through all the years of sucking and
bailing and continue to stay on and
research and get better and improve it's
just the passion for the work you just
love it so much when you find the thing
that you love so much you would do even
if you weren't getting paid to do it
that's when you spend so much time added
that you get to be Michael John level
talent that's when you start to win
let's keep it going the rule number
eight find Mentors
what do you say to someone while saying
oh nobody around me believing in me and
that's okay if you have that that's
great if you don't have it yeah it's
okay I for years read books of people
who I didn't know but I considered them
at my personal mentors I I said it
Winston Churchill who said the truth is
conscious incontrovertible malice mere
tacit ignorance they derided but at the
end there it is I said it Earl
Nightingale who said all of us get in
life what we are not what we want all of
us are self-made but only the successful
will admit it so I studied these people
and they mentor to me I feel their
spirit sigh I surrounded myself in my
bid with their books and their law do in
my imagination and listening to their
audio programs yes so how much does the
library call
card costs it's free in the United
States I don't know what in your country
so I suggest that you spend time working
on yourself study the high achievers I
did that to find out how did they get
there I study the life of Frederick
Douglass who say we won't get everything
that we fight for but everything we get
it will be a fight and so as you study
these people and imagine yourself in
their position and in your mind's eye
say to yourself as I did if they can do
it I can do it they put their pants on
one leg at a time they breathe air just
as I do and so I believe that what you
would you focus on the longest becomes a
strongest what we think about we bring
about when you train your mind to serve
you yes by reading a minimum of twenty
to sixty pages a day listening to audio
programs writing goes down reaching
reading them three times a day
you're literally creating a new mental
blueprint and imagining and seeing
yourself already living from the goal
you begin to do some things that would
most people look at it and see as
magical so this ties in nicely with rule
number six which was upgrade your
relationships I love that as he's
talking about mentorship it's not just
the face-to-face you can learn a lot
from reading a book from watching videos
if you are fan of Les Brown you've gone
to his speeches you watch any videos at
length he's always quoting a bunch of
different people whether it's burl
nightingale whether it's Winston
Churchill whether it's whoever he's
always pulling passages and quotes from
different people and by consuming all
that different stuff it helped make him
the best version of himself and so for
you who are the mentors in your life who
are the people who you aspire to be
aspire to learn from aspire to be like
right and and researching them it's why
I started this YouTube channel is why I
have content three times a day because I
want to learn from Les Brown because I
want to learn from Steve Jobs and that
helps me be the best version of me let's
move to rule number nine be willing to
work there's no secret to success
there's a system to success and no
matter what organization you become a
part of the system works if you work it
if you don't work it it won't work but
it works
if you
work it and that's one four-letter word
that most people don't like they're not
willing to work I have a friend who
invited me to her brother's house to
help him to get off drugs to introduce
him to a drug program that can help him
and and I said these people can help you
but you've got to be willing to do the
work and after we finish he asked us to
leave and I'll never forget what she
said as we were going down the steps
she said less I do apologize for wasting
your time but I realize when my brother
knew that it would require work for him
and get off drugs that most people won't
participate in their own rescue and
there are people who will be presented
with an opportunity who know that they
could be laid off at any moment who know
that there's no such thing as job
security who know that them keeping
their job has nothing to do with how
good they are and yet in still they'll
go to work and have knots in their
stomachs hoping when they open up an
email that they have not been told this
is your last day they'll go to work
hoping there's not a security guard
standing by their desk with a box and
say empty your things in here and take
them to the front door and escort them
to the parking lot they go in there
hoping it doesn't happen why because
they don't want to do the work it's an
aversion to most people's spirit guys
hard work is your ticket in it doesn't
guarantee success there's lots of people
who work hard and don't reach their
goals but there's nobody who reaches big
goals without working hard it's just
your ticket in you have to do it and if
you're not working hard enough I would
challenge you to increase the quality of
your goals and then change your
environment and your habits to support
you being productive every single day
doing things like watching Les Brown
these kinds of videos to get you
motivated excited
and feeling the feeling that you want to
go off and do something important every
single day let's finish it off with rule
number 10 be aligned with your purpose I
mean look what you and I I'm sure you do
and I'm transparent so I talk about this
I know I'm at the you know closer to the
end of my career than the beginning of I
don't think so no no because part of
delivering this message when you in
alignment with your purpose and I
believe that gives you more time on the
universe yes look at me that I'm 72 but
I don't look it I don't have a 72 year
old energy and there's a difference
between that that physiological age and
that spiritual age and I think when you
are in alignment in doing what you're
supposed to do that pleasures God yeah
yeah that it keeps you young do you have
the energy of a 20 year old yeah yeah
and so that allows you to be I mean
there's going to be a time when you and
I are not live in these bodies honest
without any question and I'm not looking
forward to that I really like that
message and I think it rounds up really
nicely with rule number one that was
don't lose time in that I want to be
that guy when I'm 72 years old and older
still loving what I do still feel
aligned with the mission still believing
in people even on a bigger scale I don't
want it just scares me so much to be
that guy who just has kind of given up
and just reliving the past and the best
years are behind me as opposed to like
what I'm doing right now is the most
amazing thing ever
so thank you guys so much for watching
I'd love to know what message you take
away from Les Brown that you were going
to immediately apply somehow to your
life or to your business leaving the
comments below
really curious to find out for me it was
rule number one don't lose time I'm
terrified of it I don't want to lose 14
years of my life or five years of my
life or one day of my life I want every
minute to count and being around less in
this video and other entrepreneurs who
preached the same message just continues
to reinforce that today matters that I
need to take action that my big goals I
need to continue to shoot for and I love
it I love it I love it I love it I love
it but what was your favorite role let
me know and why now I made this video
because Sahil bisaya asked me to it is a
famous entrepreneur that you I made a
profile next check out the link in the
description you can go and cast your
vote on the request line I also want to
give a quick shout out to Beau Hawkins
from four-minute masters beau thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word doing the profile on your
YouTube channel I really appreciate the
support man and I'm so glad you enjoyed
the read hey guys today we're gonna be
talking about Eddie Carmichael's your
one-word the powerful secret to creating
a business life that matters so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
how people live their lives as a result
of the story they believe about
themselves and when you have your
program and your guess and as this your
ideas of how they move through the
things that affect them what you do is
interrupt their story I tell speakers I
train speakers how to discover their
story how to tell their story and how to
transform people individually and
collectively by creating an experience
when I came into the speaking industry
was based upon the the book Thinking
Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill and Napoleon
Hills book was a good book and they
considered that the Bible of the
motivational speaking industry well I
come to know because of my mentor Mike
Williams in Columbus Ohio he wrote the
book called the road to your best stuff
he said less if information could change
people everybody would be skinny rich
and happy so he said in order to change
people you have to create a significant
emotional event that you have to
interrupt a person's story that they
believe about themselves with your story
and through the delivery of your stories
strategically you dismantle their
current belief system and inspire them
to make new choices because at the end
of a presentation if you don't change
how persons see themselves and if you
don't expand their vision of themselves
beyond their mental conditioning and
their circumstances and begin to allow
them to get a larger vision of
themselves and begin to ignite their
spirit you touch their hearts and as a
result they leave your presence feeling
better about themselves but making new
choices because when you change how they
see themselves all you have to do after
that is to get out of the way success to
me is doing that which resonates with
your heart then provide some quality of
service to others when you're doing that
in my life I help people to change their
lives and and when I do that you know
love happiness and inspiration or
perfumes you can't sprinkle on others
without getting a few drops on your cell
why are you here what's your reason for
being why do you get up in the morning
most people don't have a clue
and yeah the bills keep a roof over your
head I think we have to reflect on Who
am I why am I here what drives me if I
died today what three words what I want
said about me if I died today you know
what is it that defines me you know and
how how do i define myself most people
allow their circumstances to define them
as opposed to defining themselves and
how they're going to show up in life and
so my mission is to help people to
connect with the power they have within
their greatness when you're pursuing
your greatness you don't know what your
limits are so you act like you don't
have any and when you live from that
place you can now be able to make a
greater contribution and make a greater
impact with your life raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people need passion
and not one drop of most self-worth
depends on your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be
that are completely incapacitated hey
believe nation if you want to see my
all-time favorite top ten roses success
I have a very special secret video for
you these are the individual clips that
I have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link in description for
details